lori lightfoot is the progressive
mayor of chicago this is a woman who at
the height of the pandemic was telling
everyone to stay home and stay masked
who was out on the streets unmasked with
the rioters as they were burning down
her city as you know chicago which has
some of the strictest if not the
strictest gun laws in the country also
has an insane amount of gun murders
every weekend could we get the numbers
on the gun murders of chicago this past
weekend
she has defunded the police she has
brought in every idiotic progressive
policy possible we've got the numbers
already at least 46 people were shot in
chicago this weekend now why is it why
is it that you wouldn't have heard about
that
hmm
is it that they maybe want to cover it
up because they don't like the skin
color of the people who did the shooting
and who got shot it doesn't fit the
narrative could that be it could it also
expose that the gun laws that these
ridiculous people have don't work at all
yeah yeah anyway
she uh she defunded the police chicago
is a freaking nightmare at the moment
much like portland much like seattle
much like san francisco much like la you
guys get it all but now she has the gall
the absolute gall
to blame the business owners and this is
very much like a video we showed you
about two weeks ago remember we had a
video out of minnesota where ilhan omar
who also defunded the police in
minnesota where she was blaming the
police officers now for not doing their
job so she defunds the police crime
increases murder increases general
mayhem and chaos ensues and then she
blames the people that she defunded in
the first place well here's just a short
video of lori lightfoot blaming the
business owners for not doing enough to
protect their own businesses
i'm disappointed that they're not doing
more to take safety
and make it a priority for example we
still have retailers that won't
institute um plans like having security
officers in their store making sure
that they've got cameras that are
actually operational
oh god she's so ridiculous so you defund
the police people feel that they can
commit crimes more we know about all
these das who don't prosecute crimes
right so you're allowed to steal a
certain amount of stuff and instead of
her looking in the mirror although i can
get why she doesn't want to look in the
mirror
instead of her looking in the mirror and
saying oh maybe i had something to do
with this maybe my policies even though
i think i'm a good tolerant progressive
and everything i do is good just because
i believe it's good uh maybe my policies
are increasing crime right like i did
this now this happened maybe there's a
connection you know who knows
instead of doing that though she's
blaming the business owners for not
having more security in their stores you
know in a sane society you wouldn't need
a lot of security in stores um in just
think anyone watching this think about
your childhood wherever you went if you
went to a drugstore if you went to a
clothing store you went to a sneaker
store usually they didn't have security
maybe occasionally at some stores like
at a best buy they'd have a guy at the
door right because there's a lot of you
know electronic equipment expensive
stuff but you could walk into a foot
locker and there wouldn't be a need for
a security guy there you could walk into
h m and it's not like they're really
worried that someone's gonna steal that
six dollar t-shirt but now all of these
stores have security guys and it's
because
the government is not doing its job it's
in a direct dereliction of its very duty
so she's blaming the stores for not
doing enough the stores which are
already struggling by the way they're
struggling because the economy ain't
great sorry joe the stores are
struggling so maybe they can't even
afford to have these people there right
they can't afford to hire more people
when you're struggling it's basic math i
know those guys don't like math either
so
what do we do what do we do when you
have a whole bunch of politicians who
don't understand or are intentionally
doing it i mean actually i'm tired of
giving these people uh you know the good
intentions thing okay like oh your
intentions are good well if the results
are always bad at some point we can't
play that game anymore so either she
wants to destroy chicago or she's an
idiot i i don't know what the two
options beyond that would be so she's
blaming they're not hiring enough
security even though it should be her
job to make sure that you know we we
live in a that her constituents live in
a lawful city and they don't have enough
cameras there well the cameras are
meaningless too because if she's if they
caught all the people stealing the crap
they wouldn't prosecute them anyway
right we know this i mean every day you
go on twitter at any given moment
there's just endless looting happening
all over the country and it's like yeah
it's all caught on video but
they're not gonna do anything about that
so lori lightfoot i don't like you